now if you are having a trouble against
the stone wall then congratulations on
clicking this video
because after watching this not only you
are going to equip with a surprise
weapon against this opening but the
biggest plus point is let's say even
though your opponent doesn't fall for
the Trap not to worry as black still
obtain a very decent position
the opening goes as follow D4 here it
doesn't matter whether you are Knight to
F6 or D5 player let's say black plays
Knight to F6 and after E3 indeed D5
happens
well we have the trademark Stonewall
attack move Bishop to D3 whereas I have
highlighted by the arrows white has a
very effective plan of campaign what
they want to do is
play F4 and then launch this Knight on
E5 with some amazing King side activity
okay against this my recommendation is
you continue with E6
and the main line start with Knight to
D2 however if we continue with F4 then
this is slight inaccurate choice because
black can now put the Knight on e4 and
white really don't want to give up the
bishop pair and give black a center Pawn
so if he can't do that then black has a
very simple plan in the near future he
wants to play F5 a kind of Riverstone
wall
where not only white has completely
given up the opening Advantage but he
has hardly any attacking chances in this
line
so that is the reason why
the main line continue with Knight to D2
stopping our night Zone and accordingly
we will respond in the center with C5
okay if I take it then we are more than
happy
and the threat is C4 so all the games in
the database continue with C3 giving the
bishop an Escape Route
afterwards Black come up with another
forcing Knight to C6 sovere threat is E5
and white need to prevent this by
playing F4
where we have reached the most important
Junction of this line
now if you check out the database here
maimu is not even in the top choices so
you can see the surprise value
you can deliver on the board
as not many white opponents are going to
prepare for it
are you ready just look at this guys
a wonderful trappy move which sets up
the platform for our upcoming high
profile trial
and I must tell you that after this
majority of my opponent continue with
Knight to F3 which is in fact as per the
database
most frequent choice
but I'm afraid after this move what is
completely losing
yup you heard it right
and before I show it to you I would like
you to pause this video and find it by
yourself how that can happen from this
position
did you find it let's check out
the first move is very obvious
taking on D4
white has three ways to capture this
pawn and amongst them the least capture
is Knight captures D4 where the reason
is very obvious
the backward E3 Pawn can create some
huge problem in the upcoming middle game
and I have attached a sample line in the
PGN which clearly demonstrate the black
opening advantage
so nope that's not the right idea
generally the correct capture in the
Stonewall is e captures D4 but here it
is not possible as now black and simply
capture on F4 and become a clear Pawn
advantage
surprisingly enough this position also
contain a trap that if White Castle on
the king side then after Queen to E3 we
nap the piece so that is right out of
the equation
and the most accurate move Knight to E4
doesn't work out here as black and
simply put the queen back on the C7
Square
whereupon a sample line can goes like
this Knight takes F6 Pawn takes F6
opening up the G file and the point is
when White Castle on the king side
we can play Bishop to D7
whereas I have shown by the arrows very
simple yet effective plan of campaign
with Castle on the queen side and with
the healthy Pawn Advantage I think it is
why who is really struggling in this
line
so if your opponent take with the E Pawn
then black can really get the free Pawn
with a massive advantage in the upcoming
middle cave
finally we come to the point where if
you look at the database the Top Choice
is C caps is D4 not blundering the pawn
and white wants to continue with his
usual Stonewall attack more order
but exactly here
we unleash the amazing high profile trap
and let's start with night before
where white response is false he has to
move the bishop on the B1 Square
if he goes to anywhere else let's say
Bishop to B5 check then after simple
Bishop to D7
Bishop takes and Knight takes actually
there is nothing white can do to prevent
us putting the Knight on the juicy C2
Square
so nope that's the reason why exactly
here white has to play Bishop to B1
controlling the C2 square and after this
no wonder many white players are more
than happy as they think that okay I'm
going to kick this Knight with A3 and I
get my dreams Stonewall setup
well the matter of fact is
yup they can do it but this is exactly
black ones as after Black's necks
stunning reply
Bishop to D7
we get a completely winning position
from the opening stage
well the threat is very obvious Rook to
C8 and then jump on C2
which can be hardly stopped but the
biggest question comes here that what
about the move A3
kicking this Knight immediately
and can't what is better from here
of course not as believe it or not but
white has straight away fallen into our
trappy territory and the trappy business
start with this remarkable move
Rook to see it
what a move
fasting first you cannot even touch this
Knight and the reason is very obvious
after a captain's B4 we play Queen
capture seven where the end result after
the accurate sequence Castle
Queen takes Queen Rook takes D1
and okay white has a threat on A7
so we need to play A6
but now we have a threat on B4 and can
white prevent this
you can work it out by yourself black
emerge with a clear Pawn advantage in
this line
so now since a captures B4 is not
working
the only accurate choice is Castle on
the king side Defending Your Bishop
but unfortunately this allow what
actually black wants to do
namely Knight to C2
forking two guard so white response is
force he has to eliminate this Knight
and then eliminate the queen where the
end result black has posted The Rook on
the second Rank and as I have shown by
the arrows very simple plan of companies
you want to take out this bishop and
then put the other Rook on the C file
which gives him a completely winning age
well to close out this ideas I like to
show you a grand master game where black
finish up the white in a star
here white continue with Knight to E5 a
typical stone wall jump okay black plays
Bishop to D6 and after Knight to M3
black also calmly put his Knight in the
center
okay why take on D7 removing the
dangerous bishop and after King takes D7
his idea is to plonk the other Knight on
the E5 Square
but this simply allowed more
simplification with Bishop takes E5 F
takes E5 and now F5 where clearly white
Bishop cannot come out where Black
Knight is dominating the book
in fact white immediately made a mistake
here by capturing this Pawn
which allows to open the G file
and still look at that pathetic Bishop
you cannot move it anywhere
okay why Try B4
and now since the G file opener
even a kid can understand what to do
Rook to G8 G3
and no price for guessing Black's next
reply which is very obvious
H5 H4 ripping apart the white king
okay white provides some resilience with
Rook to F4 stopping our H4 idea but now
black switched the gear with Rook to C8
attacking on C1 which has once again
nowhere to go so white responses forms
so white response is force he has to
defend this bishop but after all of this
finally the H4 deliver on the board
where unfortunately for white he cannot
take this Pawn
due to the simple reason Rook to ghf
King to H1 and Rook to G2 are completely
demolition job
on the second rank
so that is right out of the equation and
in the game white right the move G4
but this again fails due to the simple
move S3 where Rook to G2 is a big time
thread
and all the time in the world
this bishop is really a big time
liability
well finally why tried the move A4 so at
least he can free up the bishop but it
is too little too late as after Rook to
jitu Chair King to H1 and Rook to C2 I
think game is already a corner
he tried Rook to F3
but after night you have to chat white
is forced to give up the exchange
and probably as a desperation he played
Bishop to E3 and then resigned the game
in the view of a forcing Checkmate which
I'm sure you immediately spotted
Rook to G2 and after King to F1 we have
a picture as Checkmate on the board
which obviously confirms how deadly this
opening trap can turn out against the
Stonewall
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap in the
Stonewall attack remember when your
opponent plays the move Knight to F3
shock him with this capture on the D4
and when white plays the obvious
sequence that is C captures D4
deliver this surprising Goods night to
before
Bishop to B1 and Bishop to D7 where
after A3 and Rook to C8 it is why who
has fallen for the Trap and no matter
however he plays it is black who get a
completely upper hand from this position
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
buy and take care